just one time racism saved my life me
and I was I was on a plane
I was coming I was coming from overseas
and I don't know how this guy got a
machine gun on the plane but he stood up
and he said everybody get on the [ __ ]
ground nobody look at my face I started
freaking out cuz he was Chinese I was
like why is he talking like that
[Applause]
with screaming a crime I was the only
brother on the plane well I thought only
brother I looked over there was one of
the black dude he's from Nigeria I
looked over them he was looking right in
my face man
he didn't say two words to me just like
the music
didn't need to talk I know we just was
talking about looking right back at him
let's write some white dudes on the
front of planes seen us ooh my god
[Applause]
riah does communicatin that we
understood the situation we were both
seeing the same thing what we understood
was simple terrorists don't take black
hostages that's the truth I have yet to
see one of us on the news reading the
hostage of energy they is treating us
good we are chilling this [ __ ] I'd like
to give a shout-out to Ray Ray a big
Steve
[Applause]
you're not gonna see it terrorism smart
they know what they're doing there you
know they terrorists they know what the
black people's bad bargaining chips they
called the White House hello we have got
five blood hello
[Applause]
I'm having an artistic dilemma I have
two poems one poem is older and one poem
I just wrote backstage which one would
you like to hear wait how many for the
old one
how many put a new one all right so
remember if it sucks you asked for it
[Applause]
one night at 3:00 a.m. I went to the
corner store I forgot why oh that's
right I wanted to bite I had the
munchies because I was hired the store
is owned by mr. Fong and every day sees
me he does me wrong he's Korean
now I'd never say I hate all Korean
people I haven't met all Korean people
that hate talks for savages but even
though I don't generalize I do do
percentages and averages
[Applause]
so far I hate 1 out of 5 Korean people
have been faithful
so I come in the store hello mr. fall I
say
and he just scows with me and growls at
me by something hearty up now look I'm
not stealing in the least but if you're
shopping and you know someone's watching
your shop bet you to make you look like
a thief
[Applause]
he's long said hey I've been watching
you since you came in the door buy
something now or get out of my store now
I couldn't take it anymore hey hey I
said raising my hand take your fingers
out of my face
[ __ ]
[Applause]
first of all say hey hey what make you
think of Chinese you must not know it
just sin you made a mistake breckman at
least know Fung is Corinne now I was
wrong I was wrong I said mr. Fung I'm
sorry to offend by mistake in your race
but you gotta admit if it was a Chinese
look-alike contest your ass would place
you're a dead ringer for Chinese but
don't be mad at me I didn't mean to
offend you in the least you know some
people say all black people look alike
we call those people police thank too
much [ __ ] out there to stress you out
whole world is drug infested hate
infested drug infested worl hate drugs
heard the worst drugs three no my friend
told me you know what he's dealing with
his landlord is hooked on crack that's
that's terrible as pressure your
landlord's hooked on crack that means
you gotta have the rent not even due yet
it's too tense
let me just get $20 of it now and then
it's gonna risk the other one every
couple hours Hey look I'm gonna need
some more of the Ring buildings falling
apart things came up comes home early
for the party landlords in the crib
going through his [ __ ] buddy go to my
house ah where's the sink I came to fix
it send the kitchen I thought it was in
the drawer I'll fix it tomorrow when I
come for the rent
can I help out drugs I hate one like
people my age and older get hooked on
crack I hate that [ __ ] ooh
you're too old to be experiment with the
drugs at a certain point you should be
past that ain't doing it by a certain
point you just miss it drugs are really
bold people anyway you 75 you learn to
write [ __ ] I'm 575 I do coke heroin
everything I want to give a [ __ ] I've
been walking down the street that guy
boy that old man is tripping
[Applause]
can't do everything maybe we'd we're
gonna do something do Louise smokes we
weeds not as bad as everything else
Swede is a background substance only you
can smoke some herb and still function
and you ain't crisp but you'll function
nothing higher than weed though I made
that mistake one time I house at a party
some guy gave me some shitty zai here
man take this
it's [ __ ] mushrooms I took it I
forgot all about it you know then a
couple days later I found it in my
pocket I'm thinking why not
cuz I'm thinking it's like we some
background [ __ ] I plan my whole day out
like it was we I'll chew his [ __ ] up
then I go to the barber shop get my hair
cut and then I'll see a movie
I chewed it up so far so good
then I was in a barber shop like an hour
later and it's funny because I was just
thinking my son's like oh this stuff
sucks
tastes like athlete's foot
I feel sick but I'm not really high then
I looked in the mirror I saw the Baba's
reflection man it looked like it looked
like a big penis was cutting my hair
free cap I started talking myself Dave
calm down you're on drugs
this is what drugs do you know that
there is no way that a penis can cut Hey
I started freaking out man I just
couldn't take it anymore I jumped out
the chair half my hair was cut I didn't
care I mean I just gave a bob my hand
full of money it was weird the balls
opened up
anyway I I ran home and I'm paying home
as fast as I could
stripping stripping I look at the clock
it was 242 I was like damn
242 I gotta stop around them I've never
been this high this early i took a
shower i was still had said maybe
musical do the trick I listened to every
CD I had I was still hot exercise that's
what I'll do
I ran around the back for pounds still
hat took the nap woke up [ __ ] up
I look at the clock it was 243 yes a guy
scared to death of these police
I am the guy I got a police scanner
first first money I got this the first
and I went to both men police can I just
listen to these month [ __ ] before I go
out just to make sure everything's cool
you hear [ __ ] on it
calling all cars calling all cars be on
the lookout for a black male between 4 7
and 6 eighties staying in the kree of
the night at work on that alibi for a
minute every black person needs Alabama
I do them impromptu joins if I'm by
myself and need out I just open up the
windows and apartment turn on lights on
stop beating old Frankie look at me note
the time of the [ __ ] - 35 look at me I'm
jerking off the window - 35
comedian Asian males June 10th note the
time that she could save my life
officer David Chappelle couldn't have
done that I saw him in his window
masturbating from 235 to 237 I'm certain
of it
he was standing on a clock I'm holding a
calendar and today's paper [ __ ] I need
alibis I can't be no celebrities [ __ ] is
just the worst I'm seeing it I can see
why I see why stars are crazy man these
[ __ ] I went to Disney World
with my kids which is a big deal for me
I don't see my kids so much
I do Chappelle show 20 hours of baby
sleep for like half an hour raise my
kids to 10 20 minutes and not go back to
work now this particular day I got to
hook up with the kids we wouldn't the
Disney World
everybody at the park [ __ ] everybody
hey hey Rick James [ __ ] hey Rick James
pH as I aim at a you might not call me a
[ __ ] in front of my kids
timeout [ __ ] we take a day off
even Mickey Mouse did it I said this is
the most unprofessional [ __ ] I have ever
seen in my life I was fed up I caught
that [ __ ] with the uppercut not
to see it clean off everybody was
screaming oh my god oh my god
Mickey Mouse is Mexican I don't deal
with jails don't deal with jails and I
don't deal with police my house got
robbed and New York I didn't even call
the police I wanted to but I couldn't my
crib is too nice it's not that it's too
nice but it's too nice for me oh he's
still here
open and shut case Johnson currently
this black guy broke it and hung up
pictures of his family every way never
seen anything like it
don't deal with the man I had to bail a
friend of mine out of jail one time you
know that was horrible I was scared I
had to walk right into the belly of the
beast I tried to look as non-threatening
as possible hi I'm here to bail out my
buddy oh okay well while you're here you
do fit a description you'll walk this
way we can process you spit in those
damn descriptions that could be bitter
and blame all the police but now I'll
tell you who I blame Stowe's sketch
artist
they keep drawing the same brother
who is this generic man we all look like
I don't know what they say when it says
Haley be and they were like did you get
a look just see the guy that tried to
rob you yes yes I did he's about six
feet tall I'd say six feet tall yes
he had his hat on backwards too good
that's good stuff was on backwards yes
it was black okay big lips big nose
hanging out say no more sir drawn from
memory now let me get my stencil I think
we can trace this guy and same same time
I've been accused of having sex with a
girl I did not have sex with before let
me tell you something
that [ __ ] is infuriating you ever go
through that thing you know it'll make
you crazy we screaming at your best
friends I didn't touch that fish think
I'll kill you [ __ ] you me I can't you
please believe me
me the Clinton didn't do it like that
did it
Clint came out of the press conference
all relaxed shoulders all relaxed and
all this trouble look I just got done
[ __ ] listen let me tell you something
America I don't think you heard me
first time I did not have sexual
relations with that woman miss Lois
[Applause]
everybody know that finger smell like
nobody can
nobody care we all watched we was
disgusted when we kept watching the news
I know I did I was taping it so how did
the crib like maybe turn the lights off
news is coming home every week on 60
minutes was a different girl accusing
Clinton when Kathleen Willey came out
she was upset the president called me
into his office he began
Saji my breasts so I'm sorry
and then I placed my hand on his
genitals and Bradley was shocked
who
was he aroused oz at home like yeah was
he arousal
and then aunt Bradley look right in the
camera is it don't bust that nut yet
we'll be right back oh man a news and
there have been so good but there were
no victims there were no victims only
when I feel sorry for is that a Lewinsky
a little cyber I don't feel oh sorry
bird oh god damn I'm not the one yeah
yeah well Hart has a hard thing to be
famous for me yeah nobody want to be the
most famous [ __ ] of all time I
feel bad for not even know that as
jealousy that's what that is I mean come
on that's one dignity that girl's
suckered it's gonna haunt her for the
rest of her eye long after she spent
that money up that's still gonna haunt
her I know there's a lot of women in
here with at least one dick they regret
and I bet you what a presidents dick I
bet she worked at can issue the Safeway
see we got to stop judging people that
girl was young and she made a mistake
that young girls make she wanted to [ __ ]
a powerful man period that's as far as
she thought it through
she wasn't thinking how powerful the
president was she had no wisdom Oh - I'm
gonna helped everybody older woman would
have been in there you know you should
lower taxes that is my grandmother's
thing that really cleaning up as a Negro
spiritual black work song not everybody
know about that see white people you
guys my whistle when you work
but that's how you can tell what kind of
work we're actually doing
[Applause]
I said it kind of I do anything that has
to do with race I read a little here see
a little there and I travel that's
always good
traveling is mainly a racism kind of
sewer if you will you know it's
different from region to region anyone
ever been down south so you guys know
what I'm talking about and the racism
now now it's just still do a perfection
comfortable it's out in the open
there are no secrets in Mississippi
everybody knows the deal
[Applause]
Matt up here you hit the big cities man
it's different it's always a secret and
we should be like there we should keep
up without know when been a little I
mean with limits you don't want to say
whatever comes to your mind it might be
a little much
why do be walking down the street man in
this business the brother walk up to him
hello you write oppressor you slave
master rapist of Africa to go why hello
my big lip spear chucking friend to say
so why do what did you do today huh
oppress a new land and make the people
there Christians against their will what
did you do fellow burn those big black
lips on a crack pipe as your least your
job it'll be easy why do you couldn't be
well this chitchat has got me thirsty
you will excuse me for a moment I'm
gonna go to the Korean store get
something to drink you spanner dad ruin
the economy in our neighborhood well but
it still isn't taking the money out the
community
well good afternoon you browse around
but never buy anything
[Applause]
and the Lao that might be too much
[Music]
she can't help it if you an American
you're racist we brought up from the
beginning to think in generalizations we
never look at that never visual we
rarely look at individual I'm a racist I
know I'm a race there's no how no the
other day I caught myself being racist
against myself there's so much you know
and I got mixed up forgot whose team I
was on
what time I was reading the paper man
this story came on about the UH
this guy was suing a department store
because they wouldn't let him play Santa
Claus you know cuz he's black and I was
actually like relieved when the
department store beat him that's bad but
I wasn't ready for that
I wasn't ready for the idea of a black
Santa Claus man it would suck we
wouldn't get our presents to the 28th
[Applause]
Santa got caught at lisam Vegas
I had to sell some toys to get back
where them cookies it said I'm in the
wrong business actually the president
she know I'm in the wrong business
the only reason what the president is
cuz I'm black doesn't make it too hot
for me I mean I mean it could be a black
president one day but you don't wanna be
the first one I mean second the third
that's family that first [ __ ] better
watch out I'm gonna tell you that right
now - ha I may not be the first black
president I don't think that nobody
would really really hurt me I'm sure
somebody want to hurt me but I don't
think they touch me because uh because
my vice president will be Mexican will
insurance
because shoot me if you want but you
just go open the border up so
you might as well leave me and vice
president Santiago to our own devices
hey that right side the OP see
[Music]
Galion can stay don't worry don't worry
I don't got no alien jokes all I'll say
by Eliana's thank God is Cuban
as if he was Haitian you'd have never
heard about his
[Applause]
Italian Elian Gonzalez was le on the
moon bow from heaven way to push a
little rubber to right back in the one
side
[Applause]
other thing if somebody slept with so
much stuff to worry about you know the
more you know the more you don't know
who and [ __ ] you know like a lot of
people will be telling me Dave you know
he just got relaxed the racism thing we
bugging you too much everything about it
sometimes she don't happen you know a
lot of black people can relate to just
have you ever had something happened
that was so racist that she didn't even
get mad he was just like he was like why
you almost like it didn't even happen he
was like a [ __ ] movie it was I used
watching Mississippi Burning why haven't
I was in Mississippi I was in
Mississippi doing a show and I go to the
restaurant to order some food and I say
to the guy I said I would like to have
and before I even finish my sentence he
says the chicken I could not believe it
could not believe that [ __ ]
this man was absolutely right I said how
did he know that I was gonna get some
chicken
I have someone so how you know that how
did you know I was gonna get some
chicken you look at me like I was crazy
come on buddy come on buddy
hey everybody new shows you off to the
goddamn door you're gonna get some [ __ ]
it is no secret down here that blacks
and chickens are quite fond of one
another then I finally understood what
he was saying and I got upset
I wasn't even man I was just upset I
wasn't ready to hear that [ __ ]
all these years I thought I liked
chicken because it was delicious
turns out I'm genetically predisposed to
liking chicken
I got no say in the man I got ruined
chicken for me I'm scared eat it in
public I know I want some I see me and
say something some chicken look at him
he loves it
just like it's in the encyclopedia happy
looks
sometimes a killer doing that show
business big crazy that's what the
culture is really collide show business
bring a lot of races together sometimes
it works sometimes it don't
this is one thing that happens it's
funny you know sometimes I'd be on a
business call right you know like with a
with a lawyer some I'll always be right
and and I will be on the call all right
and they'll be like oh okay Dave we're
gonna we're gonna close the deal is that
fine with you okay that's good for me
great great you have a good weekend Dave
I'll be like all right you too man
peace oh all right bye-bye
what the saying right so sometimes
sometimes I'll make up [ __ ] that's not
even slang just to see how they handle
it and [ __ ] me
maybe the same business go alright we're
gonna close the deals that finally do
Dave
yeah that's good to me great you have a
good weekend Dave all right buddy
zip it up and zip it out alright
somebody do now my bike
[Applause]